أعلم أنك عدت للتو عضو مجلس الشيوخ من
هذا الوفد المكون من الحزبين الذي كنت فيه ،
وذهبت إلى كييف ، وتراهن هناك مع
الرئيس زيلينسكي على مدى أهمية
هذا الاختراق الواضح الآن بالنسبة
للولايات المتحدة والحلفاء للبدء في
توفير دبابات أبرامز ودبابات ليوبارد
لأوكرانيا.  هو
ذئب مهم للغاية سمعناه مرارًا
وتكرارًا ليس فقط من الرئيس زيلينسكي
ولكن من كبار قادته العسكريين أن
هذه الدبابات تتذكر القوة النارية
والدروع التي تمتلكها القدرة على الحركة
ضرورية للدفاع ضد
الهجوم الروسي الذي
لا يتوقعه بعد شهور من الآن ولكن
بعد أسابيع حرفيًا ،
قال لي أحد القادة العسكريين الرئيسيين لماذا
لا تثق بنا في الواقع قائلاً إننا
استخدمنا ما قدمته لنا لمثل هذا
التأثير العظيم الذي دفعهم بعيدًا عن
الروس الذين أحرزوا
تقدمًا كبيرًا في  الشرق الآن وصل الصراع إلى
طريق مسدود ويريد الأوكرانيون
شن هجماتهم المضادة في
الدبابات أمر ضروري ، لكن هذه هي النقطة الأساسية أن
وقت الذئب هو جوهر الوقت ليس في
صالحهم ، لذا فهم بحاجة إلى هذه الدبابات
حرفيًا غدًا وليس أشهر من  الآن
يجب ضغط النقل التدريبي
لأنك تستمر في الإشارة إلى
السناتور هذا العام حيث يمثل
نقطة تحول حاسمة في الحرب التي
نشهدها الآن ما الذي سيتطلبه
القتال في الربيع القادم
لإقناع بوتين بأنه يستطيع ذلك ببساطة.  من أجل الفوز في
أوكرانيا ،
ما يتطلبه الأمر هو النجاح على
الأرض والهجوم الذي يضع
شبه جزيرة القرم ويشير بالقرب من الحدود
مع روسيا حتى يشعر بوتين
بقدراتهم العسكرية ، والدبابات
مهمة كرسالة إلى بوتين
بأنه  لن يكسر أو يقسم
الحلفاء كما كان جزءًا من هدفه طوال
الوقت وأنت محق تمامًا في أن
الحرب في نقطة تحول حرجة
وقت الخطر الأقصى ولكن أيضًا
فرصة كبيرة ولا يمكنني التأكيد
بقوة بما فيه الكفاية على مدى أهمية  حان الوقت وهناك
درس أكبر هنا هو الذئب
الذي أود أن أقول أنه يجب علينا جميعًا الاستفادة
من هذه التجربة ، لقد
قدمنا ​​ما هو مطلوب عندما
طلب الأوكرانيون ، ولكن في كثير من الأحيان فقط
بعد تأخير مدفعية الهايمار ،
دفاع صاروخي باتريوت بعض
الأسلحة الأخرى.
بحاجة إلى أخذ الدرس ليقول نعم ،
يجب أن يكون هذا هو
الخيار الافتراضي ، نعم حتى نجد
سببًا مقنعًا لقول لا لأن
التأخير غالبًا ما يؤدي إلى خسائر في الدماء
ويعيش في ساحة المعركة نقطة مهمة